[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
kamel tu as un petit tour de magie à
nous faire géraldine sa portée si un jeu
de cartes est tout neuf
vraiment fermé vers le haut formation
aux côtés pharma dans le bain est ce
qu'on va faire
jean vertou nous se montre inquiète car
ça c'est cadeau vraiment vraiment très
lapointe je vous vois le parquet hop je
vais confier l'étude
et si j'apporte un jeu de cartes avec
tissu des jo car toutes les cartes qui
sont classés dans l'ordre
las le 2 le 3 le 4e 5e 6e 7e 8e 9e 10e
valette à moins c'est un peu les cartes
sont passionnants
ce qu'on va faire je vais te demander
d'enlever les tirs publicitaire est de
mélanger
oui les tartes s'il te plaît géraldine
nous vraiment toutes les cartes vraiment
toutes différentes mais c'est très mal
mélange hélas le 2 mai 3e date le 5
tout ça pour faire ça faudra me dire
stop en danger sera ok ok très bien ce
que je vais faire je vais faire passer
des tartes et tu vas me dire stop quand
tu veux d'accord ok europe stop avant la
fin parce qu'après la périphérie
recommence tape très bien tu apprendras
tard c'est papa tu la regardes oui c'est
fait et je vais te demander de faire une
grosse in nature en plein milieu s'il te
plaît ok voilà très bien en plein milieu
ok ça fait très bien il reste un peu de
poids sur la tarte ouais c'est bien ce
que tu peux maintenant numéro un numéro
de portable
si madame arriva lequel souligne mathieu
non ouais tu m'as tu vu pourquoi pas ok
les gars dont on va remettre juste la
tarte ici parfait on va montrer
rapidement la caméra juste comme ça
tombe bien vu oui oui oui
parfait est ce qu'on va faire va perdre
attire dans le milieu du papier comme
d'habitude je mêle way est ce que je
vais faire je vais maintenant des
cachets si j'ai les cheveux coupés le
retour du génial
géraldine excusa seraient
impressionnants si je claque des doigts
la seule carte qui remonte sur la
tartine et ça sera passionnant et c'est
au regard du tissu parfait il ya une
carte initiale qui remonte à
j'ai dit que ça serait impressionnant
j'ai pas dit que j'allais le faire et
son coup droit très fin et qu'on fera
tout doucement sur le papier pas pu en
principe
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'on va faire on va continuer va
recommencer donc je vais prendre ici
voilà parfait on va prendre et si le
solde de karoutchi et signer des
signatures pour vivre messina turcomane
regardez bien c'est imparable tout
doucement à rivedoux approbateurs doit
remettre dans le milieu du paquet mais
simplement faisant je te sa part
exceptionnellement comme sommes sur tf1
paix je vous ai je vais vous êtes piqué
le tour ça voudrait oui on est perdant
secret est passé tour dans l'émission où
est ce qu'ils savaient même pas lui-même
comme il est ce qu'on va faire pour que
tout le monde puisse bien voir je vais
prendre le sac de carottes est signé et
je vais belattar je vais l'attendre
comme ça à partir de maintenant on va
facilement la suivre donc jusqu'ici tout
va bien
vraiment voilà on va se mettre juste là
parfait donc regarder bien je me retire
dans le milieu du paquet et pour l'avoir
monté suffit simplement faire ça une
perte de quoi faire maxime j'ai donné un
petit combinant plus des magiciens et
depuis plusieurs mois tu essaies de là
c'est dur donc je vais te montrer
comment faire d'accord tu veux faire une
grosse signature s'il te plait ça fait
très bien et une veste je me retrouve à
faire on va le laisser sécher un tout
petit peu on va prendre deux trèfles va
plier en deux et en quatre je vais
simplement te demander de mettre ses
entretiens dans ce cas pas été top sexy
j'ai fait la même chose moi le cadre de
coeur voilà qu'on montre et si pareil je
prendre la carte
je vais signer
parfait on va laisser sécher ce nom mais
ça de côté et je vais faire la même
chose que toi tu es là carton 204
contact j'ai signé la nonne question
[Musique]
aïe
biarritz ordre assez attention la beac
holla holla holla c'est chaud tu fais ça
fonctionne pas non non je peux prendre
la carte ou doucement annonçait le nom
de tous ceux chez sega adultes aux côtés
de ton côté c'est un peu mon côté avant
la mi-avril tour du web en environnement
direct et huard tombe c'est en plein
match eric berton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
camusso
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]